hey this is Moshe kasher and Natasha
Leggero we just got married six months
ago which we think pretty much makes us
qualified to give love advice to
strangers so that's what we did we
packed up the car hit the road and
spread the love yes
ma'am what's your name
vegan Megan and Zack
Megan and Zack the widest possible love
them and are you guys are you guys
married senior I've been married for 10
yrs oh wow she's only got it wrong by
six years we got a couple of good emails
from her request for people that needed
love advice to reach out to us this says
love advice drunk advised and it's from
someone whose handle is stealer girl I
think that means like it's already a bad
sign any advice on how to keep my
husband from peeing on everything when
he's drunk and sleepwalking he swears
he's just being a good boy how like in
what world would be a good boy oh like
how a dog is a good boy I guess how
about I just give her the URL to
Alcoholics Anonymous
do you have any problem with Zack yeah
pet peeve of yours about that well a
recent fight we just had oh yeah
thank you good night says Zack he told
me I had a little surprise coming in the
mail okay
Hitachi Magic Wand
he bought me that ones wait bro
Wow my oh you want to know what I don't
like about my husband I guess I would
say he bought me the best sex toy on the
market what Megan why are you mad I just
that wasn't something that I wanted as a
gift I wasn't happy about it felt
presumptuous is how you saying right oh
you got the Moshe kasher let's see if we
have another one I like this person very
exotic named knoefel knoefel me and my
girl are definitely need of love not
advices love no well that's not your
girl she lives in LA and I live in
Twentynine Palms I haven't seen her
since March March April May June that
sucks make my dream come true oh he
thinks we're gonna write him a check
also what do you kind of check you need
to write to get something from make my
dreams come true have a quarter tank of
gas I was so pissed at him I didn't talk
to him for like a week why
that is funny say oh we are done here
we know I am pissed I'll talk to you
later I'm curious was that like you were
you were like oh this is this is
something I know she's gonna like or
this is a sign or this is a message I
want her to receive what was your
instinct with that I thought she might
like it it's the best sex toy on the
market you said it's like the best
vibrator for you know women after they
have kids okay I think I may be I think
I might have found the problem you might
be bad at dirty talking what do you mean
make your dreams come true do you need
some gas money and say lovingly mo Tasha
lovingly
here's what I think you need to
incorporate this sex toy together
because I remember one time well I don't
want to say this is personal what is it
you wish oh yeah that's personal yeah
okay right right we owe it to them well
for example if you're dating someone who
watches a lot of porn you could like
I know you're right it's too personal
you could watch the porn with them and
then incorporate it like turn that into
sex or something right Natasha didn't
even know what a bbw was but you know
like why don't you not take it as like
oh this is something I'm supposed to do
on my own and this is something that you
guys do together okay so Megan could be
open to that could you do that tonight
Megan
I do the guy once that peed the bed from
being drunk and it was not fun I dated a
girl once when we would have sex she
would start screaming and then all of a
sudden like she would pee a lot like
every time I should be like oh my god oh
my god oh my god and then she would pee
sue come oh is that what that was what
is your main problem with Danny yeah yes
yeah